salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien je suis hyper content de
revenir pour cette rentrée sur Youtube
avec une série documentaires sur le
combattant français de MMA Morgan
Charrière j'ai commencé à le suivre il y
a presque trois ans maintenant et son
objectif à l'époque c'était de rejoindre
la plus grosse organisation mondiale de
combat de MMA l'UFC avec cette série de
vous raconter la réalité de la vie des
combattants tous les sacrifices qu'ils
font j'espère que ça vous donnera une
bonne perspective de leur vie il y aura
quatre épisodes un chaque jour sur la
chaîne Youtube de brut à 18h jusqu'à
l'événement
UFC Paris samedi soir j'espère que ça
vous plaira bon visionnage
ok bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui on
va parler d'une vidéo pour que on m'a
demandé de faire donc ça va être comment
passer pro en MMA
[Musique]
il y a toute une génération qui fait
savoir comment on fait tu vois pour à
l'occasion pour devenir champion du
monde prendre une ceinture pour signer à
l'UFC
jeune qui aimerait se lancer dans ce
sport pour devenir pro déjà je te
conseille de prendre ton
temps on va faire une chaîne Youtube où
on va expliquer tout OK
salut j'espère que vous allez bien
je suis ma chaîne Youtube par exemple
moi je vais être combattant de même à
essayer donc il se lance
à récupérer
forcément on est obligé d'être vrai et
de tout montrer tu vois on peut pas
tricher et montrer que la victoire c'est
en train de me tuer ça c'est le côté que
tout le monde veut montrer
[Musique]
je dirais même que c'est le côté que
tout le monde montre en général parce
que personne veut se montrer au plus bas
personne ne veut montrer sa
vulnérabilité
ok du coup j'ai pas filmé la fin de
l'entraînement mais c'était du jour on
m'a bien rouler dessus aujourd'hui
Morgan c'était le premier à mettre en
avant les galères d'être un combattant
MMA il a montré les inside du MMA
[Musique]
c'est un combattant je dirais moderne
combat depuis toujours il combat tout le
monde
c'est un combattant extrêmement
discipliné
intelligent en gros c'est un charbonneur
de la nouvelle ère
l'enfant il y a un objectif dans sa tête
c'est d'être entré à l'UFC il y pense
qu'à ça c'est l'UFC tout ce que je fais
là c'est pour arriver à l'UFC
pour moi c'est pas un rêve c'est
vraiment je vais y aller je sais pas
quand mais je vais y arriver
[Musique]
bravo Morgan super prise
alors là franchement bien
j'étais à toutes les compétitions toutes
c'est moi qui l'emmenais c'est pas le
club j'ai appris plus tard c'était même
pas légal j'avais pas le droit de
l'entraîner on va dire
nous on est en traitable avec sa mère on
voulait pas que qu'il arrête on voulait
que s'il arrêtait fallait qu'il ait la
ceinture noire
fallait qu'il était au bout
moi je suis comme ça vous emmener les
choses au bout
moi j'ai toujours voulu faire des sports
de combat ça m'a jamais vraiment
intéressé le foot le rugby tout le
basket tous les sports collectifs ça m'a
jamais vraiment intéressé je pense que
ça ça vient d'une série que j'aimais
beaucoup regarder quand j'étais petit
Walker Texas Ranger et il faisait du
karaté et moi je voulais pareil que lui
[Musique]
il y avait vraiment une différence je
pense de mentalité avec les autres qui
venaient faire leur petit sport et moi
je venais vraiment pour gagner
manger direct
ça avait pas pourquoi ils étaient là
c'est limite leurs parents il est déposé
le dimanche à la compète
moi j'arrive à la compet j'étais Walker
ça y est
j'ai gagné plein de médailles et tout
enfin c'était vraiment bien
[Musique]
alors Morgan il a fait le judo pendant
longtemps c'est ton coude qui vient
d'about
ensuite il faisait du hip-hop de
l'escalade
[Applaudissements]
oh mon dieu de l'athlétisme
j'ai fait un peu tous les sports qui ont
existé je fais de la natation j'ai même
fait du ski
a trouvé ça important que ses enfants
ils fassent du sport donc j'ai fait
beaucoup de sport je touche à beaucoup
de choses
on avait proposé à l'époque de d'être
compétiteur mais il fallait qu'il y a la
montagne et ses parents nous ont dit non
non Morgant on va rester vivre dans les
Yvelines c'est pas pour maintenant la
montagne mais c'est vrai qu'il a
toujours eu ce petit truc avec le sport
quand on est le meilleur des fois ça
implique certaines responsabilités
alors tu es con ou quoi
et je crois que c'est en première comme
tous les ans ils font du sport ils
changent ils nous a dit bon j'arrête le
judo je m'inscris au MMA
je lui dis mais
c'est quoi le MMA et là quand il m'a dit
il y a du Jésus il y a de la boxe il y
avait plein de sport
dans ma tête tout de suite j'ai dit non
et son papa a dit
laisse-le et du coup il a été faire des
entraînements donc l'appareil il y
allait après l'école et j'allais le
chercher le soir tout en faisant juste
d'eau parce qu'on voulait pas qu'il
arrête le judo
alors mon grand s'est rencontré en 2011
au lycée on avait 16 17 ans
et Morgan à l'époque c'est déjà dit à
mes mains
j'arrive à 17 ans du coup à monte à
Mantes-la-Jolie donc il y a Eduardo
Karim et moi je suis le petit qui est là
tout le temps
pour me rencontrer voilà un petit jeune
qui paye pas de mine un peu grassouillet
et qui qui veut se mettre
il était pas plus de que les autres
sincèrement c'était quelqu'un qui était
dans le ventre moule la moyenne pas plus
que les autres
alors au début je l'ai accompagné aussi
à ses combats Aubervilliers et tout ça
je l'emmenais
voilà mais ça n'empêchait pas qui qui
après fallait faire un vrai travail je
voyais plus prof de sport quand il a
fait STAPS c'était bien sa prof de sport
en plus il avait ses cours à la fac
parce que ça les gens le savent pas mais
on est
est je suis pas une maman très cool je
suis sévère je vais dire
il s'entraînait tous les jours le soir
après l'entraînement il faisait ses
courses à vélo pour gagner un peu
d'argent ça veut dire qu'il avait
clairement trois vies dans une vie et
les études le petit job à côté plus le
MMA tous les jours
j'ai fait des crêpes je fais des crêpes
j'étais crépiées j'ai été à un
Intermarché j'étais équipée de réunion
reste là pire époque de ma vie
franchement je me levais à 3h du matin
je faisais 5 heures 13 heures 6 jours
sur 7
je m'entraîner le soir parce que je suis
en format associatif on n'a pas de club
privé donc je m'entraînais à tu vois à
20h jusqu'à 22h et je me levais à 3h du
matin pour aller travailler du coup pour
moi c'était la vie c'était normal
je rentre chez moi et il faut que je
fasse ma balise pour demain et je me
disais non là je pars dans un truc
bizarre là parce que si je fais ça
pendant 20 ans je vais pas tenir quand
on a compris que c'était pas la
meilleure solution de faire les études
le travail et l'entraînement à l'époque
on avait il me semble 23 ans moi je
venais de finir mes études donc je
savais qu'elle allait gagner des sous je
venais de finir mon Master et donc je
lui ai dit écoute Morgan pendant un an
ne pense plus au travail va que à
l'entraînement financièrement c'est moi
qui vais gérer
donc c'est parti là je vais à la salle
je vais faire ma prépa physique
on a le créneau de 20h à 21h30 même à
21h20 le gardien est monté pas il était
né la lumière des fois on finissait
entre moi dans le noir d'où Charlot
froide manche la jolie quoi en
associatif
mal fourré au terme de moyens ça n'a
rien à voir avec les plus grosses sales
françaises et ses entraîneurs qui sont
extrêmement bon d'être arrivé là où ils
sont arrivés avec Morgan dans ces
conditions c'est même pas leur taf à
plein temps
nous on fait quand on part on prend nos
sur nos vacances à nous dire quelque
chose aux abonnés bonjour on y va on va
la bagarre c'est un investissement parce
que c'est notre petit c'est la famille
tu vois c'est c'est que ça
c'est le petit c'est la famille
ça a pas duré très longtemps le monde
amateur on va dire qu'il a été un an en
amateur et tout de suite il a été
champion de France et après ça va partir
de là je pense que j'ai pris un big
steps et après arrive le quai du
Warriors
[Applaudissements]
là on est à très haut niveau ceinture
mondiale meilleure organisation d'Europe
tu prends le titre tu le défends et tout
tu peux aller à l'UFC
on fait j'avais une équipe expendable tu
vois de héros avec moi personne croit en
nous tu vois tout le monde veut se dire
mais eux ils sont complètement fous on
est à trop la dalle en fait on a rien du
tout moi j'ai rien du tout j'ai que ça
genre en plus c'est vraiment c'est mon
moment
je suis à cette performance lequel je
vais avoir mon signé pour
trois combats moi direct mon objectif
c'est la ceinture à 66 kg donc l'échelle
du MMA il y a l'UFC qui est tout en haut
c'est intouchable et en dessous il y a
le ketch Warrior il y a beaucoup de
grands noms du FC qui ont été champion
du quai de voir donc c'est pas du tout
une ceinture au rabais
donc j'ai fait deux combats un combat
contre un Contenders donc qui avait
affronté l'ancien champion juste avant
je le bats
ensuite ils me mettent contre l'ancien
champion
je le mets KO
hème
donc voilà je suis le prochain à la
ceinture
un homme comme une fois de taille
un nouveau jour magnifique sur Londres
et on adore j'adore elle doit faire
proximativement 33 degrés facile bon
sinon les gars se passe bien hein
je vais bientôt arrêter de boire là je
vais avoir vite fait juste pour faire
passer tous les cachets là et ensuite je
mange tout va comme sur des couleurs
donc pour Morgan le combat contre
Périgueux c'est vraiment l'aboutissement
de quelque chose véritablement pour lui
il aimait un event c'est un combat où il
est favori et là le rêve de Morgan qui
le dit dans chacune de ces interviews
chacune de ces vidéos ok je veux aller à
l'UFC bah ça commence à véritablement
prendre de l'épaisseur
une grammaire
[Musique]
alors je fais mon entrée avec mon masque
je l'ai préparé cette entrée
le masque il veut tout dire tu vois faut
que je marque les esprits il faut que je
marque les gens je pense qu'à ça tu vois
parce que moi d'où je viens les mecs
comment on va pas jusqu'à là
[Musique]
moi je lis on s'entraîne dans un
association il y a personne qui nous
aide on a pas d'oser on devrait même pas
être là tu vois
[Musique]
c'est extraordinaire ce qu'on vit en
fait un club amateur petit club de
banlieue
occasion Warriors extraordinaire j'ai
pas de mots en fait
[Musique]
arriver à ce niveau là avec une équipe
de débutants c'était ça c'est dégâts ils
sont plein de bonnes volonté mais c'est
pas des professionnels je sais pas vous
sortez du club de Mantes-la-Jolie vous
vous retrouvez en Angleterre
au cage Warrior la ceinture mondiale
machin et les gars il d'habitude ils
font des trucs dans les gymnases ah
ouais
[Musique]
les gens comme nous on est rarement là
pour gagner à ce moment là tu vois on
nous prend pour perdre tu vois pour
servir de faire valoir pour monter la
star locale etc
[Musique]
il est monstrueux en fait
c'est un monstre
[Musique]
je fais le tour de la cage
au moment où tu fasses avast je le
regarde
il était costaud par contre il était
énorme
je regarde pas les combats je veux non
c'est pas vrai si c'est vrai il se fait
taper ça me plaît pas
c'est normal c'est mon fils il prend un
coup je le prends
le Warrior machin c'est mon fils c'est
mon petit
j'ai porté pendant des kilomètres quand
il voulait pas marcher quand il était
petit et tout c'est mon fils
[Musique]
des fois je disais oui mais faut pas
être violent il me dit mais maman le but
du MMA c'est d'être violent je suis
casse la gueule ou il me casse la gueule
[Musique]
bon bah d'accord bah alors qu'à celui la
gueule
il démarre et je lui dis casser ses
appuis
[Musique]
sur le combat qu'on lui demande quoi
le gars en face gros crochet brave il va
me les bloquer
il bloque il bloque il bloque
il y a rien qui rentre
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé je suis
dans sa tête je pense tout ce qui pense
je sais tout tu vois je vois tout
il a une gestion de la distance des
feintes et des esquives dans ce combat
là qui est fabuleux
il avance vers Goodwin il arrive à lui
mettre des coups au moment où une
réplique il y a plus personne il y a un
côté matrix
sur plusieurs cours on le voit oui oui
baisse la tête comme ça comme il sait
faire
[Musique]
c'est une masterclass trouve en rapidité
en gestion de la distance et en esquive
ce combat là
troisième rang j'y retourne
et ça déroule je vois tout j'esquive les
coups
je fais monter son cœur
je commence à le faire saigner
[__] je le tape aux jambes et à la
tête parce que ce serait pas le moment
de descendre encore
donc je le feinte en haut je lève les
mains juste il lève les mains directs
[Applaudissements]
ce moment il a été
[Musique]
pour moi c'était tout était au ralenti
levez les mains je le touche je le vois
qui descend je sais que j'ai gagné
je vais en marchant du coup jusqu'à lui
le coup au foie en fait dans les sports
de combat souvent on a l'impression qui
fait le plus mal ça va être le coup à la
tête qui vous met KO direct mais en fait
ce qui fait le plus mal c'est souvent le
coup au foie parce qu'en fait on est
complètement coupé ça fait un mal de
chien on arrive plus à rien faire et on
est obligé comme le fait périgotwin on
se recroquevillé en boule et on attend
que la douleur passe
devant
[Musique]
et ce coup pour moi il symbolise on
n'est pas loin on n'est pas loin tu es
en train de conquérir la planète MMA je
vois pas comment tu peux pas aller à
l'UFC dans les mois ou les années à
venir avec ça
[Musique]
je
pense au moment où j'ai la ceinture je
le réalise pas encore vraiment mais par
contre j'ai une sensation de bien-être
et de ah c'est genre
[Musique]
la ceinture c'est des années de travail
avec mes coachs on a travaillé comme tu
es où et tout je sais même pas un
aboutissement personnel c'est un truc
d'équipe on a trop trop trop trop trop
travaillé
[Musique]
en plus c'est pas n'importe quelle
ceinture que j'ai remporté c'est un truc
qui est Warrior
les personnes qui l'ont eu avant moi
précédemment c'est des grands noms du
MMA genre Connor il a eu la même
ceinture
on l'a fait la peinture champion du
monde et personne m'attendait on m'a
toujours sous-estimé et tout ça aussi on
va vous faire gagner
la perdre tu likes la vidéo et tu
commentes moi un petit français de
Mantes-la-Jolie
j'ai gagné la ceinture du kedge genre je
suis champion du monde
ouais je pensais le moment le plus
heureux de ma vie on continue la route
parce que
après avoir pris la ceinture il faut la
défendre et défendre une ceinture peu
importe l'organisation c'est hyper
important d'avoir la plupart des
combattants disent le plus important
pour moi c'est défendre la ceinture
parce que je pense que je suis champion
qu'à partir du moment où j'ai défendu le
titre
[Musique]
de finale
de Champions
[Musique]
la garder c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est dans la fosse aux lions tout le
monde veut ta peau
est-ce que aussi important avec lequel
je vais avoir c'est que c'est une
organisation britannique
et donc vous êtes en territoire hostile
tout de suite on sait que ça sera
compliqué derrière
tout de suite on sait qu'on est la tête
à abattre
je suis à ça du SC c'est mort tu vois je
vais pas lâcher le steak
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que cette première vidéo
vous a plu et vous a donné envie de voir
le second épisode qui sortira demain à
18h sur la chaîne Youtube de beauté
n'oubliez pas non plus que l'UFC Paris
du 2 septembre soit retransmis en direct
samedi soir sur AMC sport merci encore
pour votre soutien à demain